Okay, welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
We have some questions to go over and then we'll open it up for anybody's questions.
So the first question that we had somebody ask was this one.
Could you explain how aerosolic acid helps those with cancer?
So aerosolic acid has been shown in studies to help with cancer.
Here's one study.
This talks about breast cancer, but there's other studies with other cancers.
It induces a cell called the G1G2 arrest cell response down here, and hopefully you can
see my cursor on this.
And that's what helps, it helps slow the growth of cancer.
So aerosolic acid, if we tested that on you, so don't everybody just run out by aerosolic
acid.
So if we tested it on you, and that was what we said was help something that would nutritionally
help with your cancer in our thought process, then we put you on aerosolic acid.
So this gives you some information about aerosolic acid and cancer.
Now another reason why a person would use aerosolic acid that may have cancer or may not have
cancer is aerosolic acid has also been very helpful shown to be helpful to block the entrance
of viruses into cells.
So how a virus replicates, so a virus is a technically a living thing meeting that can't
reproduce on its own, has to reproduce in a host cell.
So when a virus enters your body, it will then attach to your cell membrane and enter into
the cell membrane, and that's how it reproduces.
Well, aerosolic acid is shown to block the entrance of a virus into a cell membrane thereby.
So you could be exposed to a virus, and if you have adequate amount of aerosolic acid,
you may not get sick because when you get sick, when you're exposed to a virus, it's not
the exposure of you to the virus that makes you sick, it's the fact that the virus starts
to replicate in your cells, that makes you sick, and if you can keep it from entering into
the cell, the majority of them from entering into the cell, you're going to certainly decrease
the replication of the virus and decrease your chance that you got sick or the sickness of
the virulence of the sickness in your body.
So aerosolic acid can be a big benefit as an antiviral agent as well.
But here we're talking about anti-cancer agent, and this increases the proliferation of cancer
in a rest cell called the G1, G2 cell.
Next question, does Dr. Conner's clinic order blood tests for patients?
If so, how can I do that?
So yes, we do order blood tests for patients, however, we don't do that frequently, and the
reason is that we don't build insurance through our clinic, so if you still have a relationship
with your local clinic, then that is one reason why you would want to keep a relationship with
your local clinic, because you can get blood tests run through your insurance, particularly
if you're on Medicare or something like that, it can be very beneficial because they can
be standard blood tests that can be covered, embedded upon your diagnosis, and if you have
a cancer diagnosis, usually they'll cover at least once a month blood tests.
If your comment would be, why don't I have insurance?
So what difference does it make?
I just rather have ordered through you.
Well, there still is benefit of getting blood tests from a local physician, because if
it's a blood test that like these need a vinyl of blood, you need a blood draw.
So if you get it from a local physician, then they can do the blood draw right there as well.
We don't do blood draws.
So long answer is yes, we do have blood tests, and there are some markers that you can test
with a finger prick test, but we do not do insurance.
So if you do have insurance, and you want to run it through your insurance, it would be
wiser for you to go through a local doctor.
And secondly, if you have to get a draw, if it's a test that you can't be done with a
finger prick test, then it may be wiser to get it done locally.
But yes, we do different blood tests.
We'll talk about a few of them in the next couple of slides here.
What's the best cancer marker, or to finish that?
How would I do so?
You just call the clinic, talk to your liaison, or call the clinic in the schedule of time
for Michelle or I, and we can talk about that.
What's the best cancer marker for melanoma?
Well, there are any good cancer markers for melanoma.
So if you go to this, this is just a screenshot of our blog post on tumor marker tests.
So tumor markers or cancer markers are blood tests that can help give you some indication
of where you're at with your cancer.
Now, again, those tumor markers in that article that I wrote are listed.
And here's the top seven.
I left out PSA because that would be very specific, obviously, to prostate.
But here's the top two markers that a person would run.
Now, these tend to be more specific to different types of cancer,
like alpha fetal protein, is certainly more specific to liver cancers,
and certain type of ovarian, attesticular cancers.
CA 15-3 is going to be much more specific to breast cancers.
So if I have colon cancer, when I run a CA 15-3, no.
I wouldn't even run that if I had colon cancer.
When I run a CA 19-9, well, possibly, because CA 19-9 can be positive for pancreatic cancer,
which is physically near the colon just to, so it's a possibility.
Very common for CA 19-9 for breast cancer.
CA 27-29, this is mainly with breast cancer,
also other female organ cancers.
CA 125, ovarian cancer, strongly positive with ovarian cancer, liver cancer,
colon cancers can be CA 125.
That being said, if you read through all of these,
there's none that are for melanoma.
But that being said, would it be wise, OK, melanoma?
Can I run a tumor marker test that runs a lot of these?
Would that be a wise thing to do?
It would be a really strong shot in the dark.
The chance that melanoma would show up positive on any of these would be slim,
but anything is possible.
So you can still run these.
It's not really super expensive to run several hundred dollars to run a tumor marker profile.
So it may be worth doing it.
If the melanoma is spread to the colon or something else,
would it show it as CA 125 then still know it's still melanoma in the colon?
It's not colon cancer.
So these are different proteins that cancers can give off.
So you see that CA 15-3, 19-9, 27-29, and CA 125, alpha-theto-feto-protein as well,
can be common with breast cancer, but a person could have breast cancer
and not show positive on any of these.
So then what good are they?
Well, in that case, they might not be any good.
That's why it is good once you first have a diagnosis of cancer to have these run.
So you could get a baseline.
Unfortunately, most oncologists don't run these on a routine basis.
And there's a reason why.
So the most oncologists won't run these on a routine basis
because these can rise and fall throughout treatment based upon a couple criteria.
So let's say you were just diagnosed with a breast cancer.
And then oncologists did run these tests
and you showed a positive 15-3 elevated above its normal range.
And then the oncologist, what's the oncologist going to recommend?
Of course, the oncologist is going to recommend surgery, chemotherapy,
or radiation or some combination thereof.
During rapid cell lysis, so radiation is going to cause a pathological death to the cell,
called cell lysis.
Normal program cell death is called apoptosis.
That's like a recycling of the cells.
If you go through apoptosis,
you won't get a spike in a tumor marker.
One of these proteins will typically spike as you go through apoptosis.
But if you go through cell lysis, you can get a spike.
Well, what's a cancer patient?
Rest cancer patient going to do, if, let's say, they do a lump back to me
to remove the tumor and start with chemotherapy.
We're going to say, started with chemotherapy.
And they do this CA-15-3 again, and it goes up like dramatically.
That's going to affect them emotionally,
and they're going to question the efficacy of their treatment.
Where in truth, it may go up dramatically
because there is cell cancer cell lysis going on.
So then the oncologist has to sit down with the patient
and talk them off the cliff and explain,
well, your CA-15-3 has gone up.
I'm pretty sure because there's cell lysis,
the chemotherapy is actually working.
You can see the shrinkage of the tumor.
I'm very confident that we're on the right path.
Don't worry about the CA-15-3.
Well, for that reason, a lot oncologist just stopped
running tumor marker tests.
Now, typically, if you're doing natural care,
you're not going to get as much cell lysis.
You're going to get more stimulation of apoptosis.
So your tumor markers typically won't rise.
They won't spike with using the knife
and using natural therapies.
They can still, but it's much less common that they will spike.
We just had a person in the office today,
her tumor markers are 27.29, dropped in half in two months.
There were three months starting care.
So they're very happy.
So they're using the tumor marker test,
the one that was positive on her, the CA-27-29,
to kind of monitor and gauge care.
So using tumor markers can be helpful.
But even when it says, okay, this tumor marker is common
with breast cancer, this one is common
with paedcreatic cancer, and this one is common
with colon cancer.
It doesn't mean that if you have colon cancer,
or breast cancer, paedcreatic cancer,
that it will even show positive.
So that's another reason why some oncologists
won't even run it.
It's they're used more so with people
that are not doing standards of care
because they're not going to get that spike
from cell lysis through natural care typically.
And they can, if they do have one that shows positive,
they can use that as a monetary device
in monitoring how well they're doing with their care.
But there's some cancers like melanoma
that typically don't show there is no real cancer marker tests
that are good for a person with melanoma.
So then how do you monitor?
Well, that's the question of the day for all cancers.
There is a perfect way to monitor any cancer.
Well, I'm doing a PET scan.
Well, PET scans only gonna pick up
if you have three million cells,
a mass that's three million cells large.
Well, I gotta do a CT scan.
Same thing with a CT scan.
You could have a completely normal CT scan
but you have multiple masses that are only a million cells large.
So nothing is perfect.
Even though something is gold standard in medicine,
it's still not perfect.
So that's the, if we wish it was just,
we live in a more perfect world, but we don't.
More questions on blood tests.
Can you order tests for Omega's and vitamin D's?
Yes, we can.
So this is a picture of a vitamin D blood spot test
from a lab called CRT Labs.
So it's a finger prick test.
So you don't have to go get a blood draw.
You can do it just from home.
We can send you a kit and you do a,
comes with instructions, you do a finger prick
and you put it and you blot it on a little blot paper
and you send it in and you get a result that looks like this.
A lot of hormone tests can be done like this.
This can test a blood spot can be done
with a number of different tests.
As far as tumor markers,
you cannot do a blood spot for tumor marker tests
that has to be in draw.
This is a fatty acid profile with a blood spot.
This is through genova labs.
This is what they measure.
There can be benefits to eat a fatty acid test
for some people.
We haven't personally done fatty acid tests on people.
Omega tests on people for quite some time.
These are more important with different issues
other than cancer,
but a fatty acid profile can be beneficial as well.
So yes, we can order these tests.
I don't currently have the kits for fatty acid profile.
We just need to order and get a few days.
We have all the ZRT kits for horrible profiles,
ZIG, copper ratios, vitamin D tests.
They're not necessary,
but they can give us good ideas about different things
so they can be have lots of benefits to them.
Next question, is it okay to have my feet on an earthy mat
while running the rife next to me during the day
or should it be done at separate times?
So remember what an earthy or grow-dead mat slash sheet is.
So this is our grow-dead sheet
that if you're gonna use this with the rife,
we just recommend you put it on the lower half of the bed.
It's connected with this little button
to a snap to the sheet.
These are metal fibers running through the sheet.
It's picking up your body, your contact with the metal fibers.
This is plugged into the ground, the center,
lower part of an outlet.
That's connected to a copper wire
that goes to your ground and your panel,
your breaker panel that is then connected to a copper wire
that goes to the ground
and your ground in yourself basically while you're sleeping.
So we do not, we do not,
send everybody home with a ground-dead sheet
because there can be negatives to a ground-dead sheet
while you're running the rife.
This is just my belief.
If you fall asleep in the rife,
all just falls onto the ground-dead sheet.
You know, then you're losing a lot of the frequencies.
It'll prefer to go towards the ground
than go through your body.
There's a reason why you use that rubber ground-dead mat
when you do the foot bath
because we want the frequencies to travel up through your body
to the ground-dead mat
so that you get those frequencies from the foot bath
through your body to that mat
because the frequencies are going to tend to travel to the ground.
And so to answer this question,
yes, it's perfectly good for you to use a ground-dead mat.
Stand on it, put it on your feet
while you're running the rife during the day.
The frequencies will go through your body and down
to your feet.
That's just fine.
I'll go through your body.
So that's perfectly fine to use.
You can use those together.
You just don't want the bulb lying on the ground-dead bat
or sheet because you'll be losing most of those frequencies.
Hopefully that helps.
Next question, can we get an exemption letter
for masks and vaccines?
And on vaccines, should we get the COVID vaccine?
So the answer is yes, you can get an exemption letter
for masks and vaccines.
I know we have numerous patients that wear masks
and have gotten the COVID vaccine, and that is your choice.
I don't think it's a good choice, but that's your choice.
So I am very outspoken about my belief in vaccines in general.
And this COVID, quote unquote, vaccine is horrific.
And I don't think it's a good idea
that anybody that has talked any cancer patient
to getting this vaccine, saying that they're at high risk
so that they should get this vaccine should go to jail.
But that's just my opinion.
So yes, we will give an exemption if you choose not to get that.
And I would strongly encourage that you do that.
So just contact the clinic.
If you need that, just email your aunt or Ashley,
and we can get that to you.
So if that's what you need.
Typically, most mass mandates are out now, but vaccine pushes
are still on full force.
And you need to educate yourself.
You need to educate yourself.
All right, with that, we will open it up for questions.
If you have a question, you can just chat that question
or again, unmute yourself if you want to speak.
And again, we're being recorded, so please don't state your name
unless you don't mind the world to know what your question is.
Hello, Dr. Connors.
Hello.
Yeah, my question is, is I'm currently taking a chemo,
a low dose chemo with a immunotherapy.
And I want to narrow when and how I can jump off that
and what's the safe way to jump off that and go on the natural?
Do we do that through?
I have very good tumor markers that tell me
when the cancer is in remission and I'm just trying
to do that safely, but I want to get off the chemo immunotherapy.
OK, we should have a conversation, you and I.
And just kind of reassess everything and look
at where we're going.
Just call in schedule that, I won't charge you for that,
but we should just talk about that separately.
Because it is different with everybody and that answer
would not be a standard answer for everybody on this,
so we'd want to get personal with that.
So let's do that.
Just call in schedule a time tomorrow or next day,
we're not going to be in because of 4th of July next Tuesday
with me and we'll chat about some different options.
OK, great, thank you.
So I do want to speak on that for that person.
In general, can a person get off of chemotherapy,
get off of immunotherapy once they start natural care?
The answer is, the honest answer is you could quit anything
anytime you want to do it.
I used to say that we live in a free country,
but I'm not quite sure about that anymore.
But certainly you could get off of it anytime you want,
but you just want it to be wise.
So if the person is doing a low dose chemotherapy,
then there's different possibilities
of different things to do.
Chemotherapies and immunotherapy are easy to just quit.
So but we don't want to be unwise about it
and if what we're doing, the chemotherapy and immunotherapy
is working and you're starting to use the rife
and you're even getting better success,
is the better success because the rife is helping the chemo
and the immunotherapy target the cancer
that we're going to stop that.
Maybe that's not the best thing to do,
but we want to assess that.
So we want to get personal about those questions.
Everybody's different.
One question that came in, how can we support and strengthen
the mitochondria if we are exposed to mold?
So the mitochondria are your energy-produced storehouses
in the cell.
So your cell have these little organelles,
a bunch of different types of organelles.
What is the mitochondria that makes ATP?
And how do you strengthen the mitochondria?
Well, there's different things that are on the market
that talk about that have different nutrition
to help strengthen the mitochondria.
The biggest thing that's going to help strengthen
the mitochondria is to decrease the things
that are going to injure the mitochondria.
The mitochondria are most injured by oxidative stress
that we talked about a couple weeks ago,
which are oxidizing agents.
So reactive oxidizing species, reactive nitrogen species,
are chemicals and toxins that damage our mitochondria
of our cells, damage our cell membranes.
That can be cancer causeers.
So antioxidants is the first thing that you think of
with mitochondrial support.
Next question, we've got a bunch coming in here.
So next question, is it a good idea to avoid hydrogen peroxide?
Cursion protocol recommends sterilizing the enema bucket
with hydrogen peroxide.
Also, I was cleaning surfaces with my students
sitting using lysol and wipes.
I used hydrogen peroxide.
So I am not a fan of orally taking hydrogen peroxide,
and I have a blog post on that
that explains the chemistry of that.
But cleaning things with hydrogen peroxide is very preferred.
So yes, clean your enema bucket with hydrogen peroxide,
clean surfaces with hydrogen peroxide.
Use hydrogen peroxide instead of bleach,
instead of other cleaning products.
You could use vinegar and water instead of other cleaning products.
Maybe alternate those.
Don't use lysol, don't use any of these chemicals.
You realize all this COVID spray
that every company is using in their restaurants and everything
is so cancer-causing, it's just mind blowing.
I just did a podcast today with a gentleman
that has, you'll be able to see it a few days
when we get it up on our blog.
He talks about toxins that he made.
He pointed out something that I had never heard before.
He said, and in the European Union,
there's over 1,300 chemicals that are banned
from external use on humans, cosmetics,
lotions, creams, 1,300 chemicals that are banned for use
on as creams, as exfoliants, as in deodorants,
deodorants on external chemicals, 1,300 that are banned.
In the United States, there's 11 that are banned.
So 1,300 things might as 11,
so 1,289 different chemicals that are used in the United States
that you're putting in lotions, chemicals, poisons on your skin
that are in deodorants, that are in makeups,
that are banned in the European Union, that are approved
in the United States.
We are just living in a toxic slurry.
So the more you can use things like hydrogen peroxide
to clean with, vinegar to clean with, much better off,
you're gonna be talking about damage to mitochondria
and oxidizing agents.
This is what we're talking about.
All these chemicals that we're exposed to that are approved
by the FDA, that are just poisonous to us.
No wonder our cancer rate is through the roof.
Next question, I am doing a coffee out of it every day
and loving it.
There seems to be a sentiment that accumulates in the tubing
is that okay?
Well, my tubing is stained brown.
Yes, that's normal from the coloration of the coffee.
What's the best way to clean it?
Well, that leads right back to the question right before.
So these people are thinking the same thing.
We use Dr. Broder soap and hydrogen peroxide not together.
So yes, that would be a good thing to do.
I would say that's just fine.
Is it normal to decline a bit before getting better
after quitting chemo and starting alternative therapies
and detoxing for sure?
So yes.
So when you are, when you're making a change,
you're starting to detox the chemotherapy.
It is normal to decline a lot even long after you do chemotherapy.
And I don't want to knock anybody that's doing chemotherapy.
So please don't take it that way.
But the chemotherapy continues to damage your liver for years
and all the detoxing in the world
are still not going to get those chemicals out of your body.
So make sure you're doing a lot of different.
The foot bath detox that will really help a lot.
Any form of detoxification that you can do
that's going to bypass your liver is going to be good.
So your coffee animals are going to be extremely beneficial
for someone who has done chemo or is doing chemo.
Sodas are extremely beneficial.
If you don't have a sauna, it's a summer.
Get out and sweat as much as you possibly can
so you can bypass the liver and detox through your pores,
your skin and hot packs over your liver, castor oil packs
over your liver, anything you can to help detox
that out of your liver, the better off you're going to be.
Next question.
I started using Everclear, 100 proof liquor.
We could stop the sentence right there
and we would have a long discussion.
Okay, to sterilize surfaces, too expensive
for the bucket I thought.
And I'm not a fan of using alcohol to sterilize surfaces.
Alcohol, 100% alcohol has other issues to it as well.
Secondly, let's talk about that just a little bit.
There's things you want to clean
and you don't want an overgrowth of bacteria.
You don't want an overgrowth of mold,
but let's not forget that a healthy exposure to bacteria
and even a healthy exposure to mold
is beneficial for your immune system.
If you are not exposed to bacteria
and you fall into the mental trap of thinking
that we need to sterilize everything,
we need to wear masks, we need to,
which is totally an unsterile thing,
but to think that if we lived in a sterile world
that we would not get sick,
you missed the whole concept
of how your immune system works.
Your immune system works by being exposed
to bacteria, viruses, parasites even, mold, fungus,
in smaller doses on a regular basis,
and different types of bacteria and viruses
in smaller doses on a regular basis.
Hence the benefit of allowing your children to go out
and play in the dirt and play outside
and be exposed to different biotoxins
so that are not pathological in their virulence
and in their level of dosage that they're exposed to
so that their immune system can recognize it
and then develop antibodies against it
so that they have, that's what the definition
of a healthy immune system is.
So if we just lived in a sterile environment
and we could somehow miraculously sterilize
everything in our environment,
this is what the FDA has been basically pushing
in the health associations have been pushing on us
for decades and certainly it's been major consequence
of what they've been trying to teach
since this whole COVID scam that's been going on.
That is totally contradictory to how your immune system functions.
You need a healthy immune system
which is defined as having as many circulated antibodies
to different types of bacteria, biotoxins, virus as possible.
That's the definition of a healthy immune system.
So you don't want to create a sterile environment for yourself.
You need to be exposed to corona viruses.
You need to be exposed to different bacteria.
You don't want to completely sterile environment
and to think that you are sterilizing your coffee edema tube,
you're not, you're cleaning it
so that you don't have overgrowth and bacteria.
You're not trying to sterilize anything.
So do not become OCD with your cleaning habits
or your sterilization habits
that could work contrary to what you're trying to do
which is trying to gain health back.
So mostly sterilize piano studio, computer lab and keyboard
for the parents that they're not freaked out
over the COVID thing.
Haven't been doing that lately then.
Okay, good.
Now we need to educate people, don't we?
Still have a lot of people very fearful
of this whole COVID thing.
You're commanded scripturally to fear God
and to fear Him alone.
You don't fear man, you don't fear a virus.
You don't fear getting sick, you don't fear dying,
you don't fear cancer.
That's disobedient
and we're supposed to be obedient to God in scripture.
We fear Him alone and we trust in the Lord
with all our heart, here's our verse right here,
Proverbs 35 and trusted Him to protect us from things.
We don't act foolishly,
but during the black plague,
it was the Christians that were going in the homes
of the people risking their life,
knowing full well that they could get the black plague
and they would be dead in three days.
They were the ones going in homes,
risking their lives, helping care for people
that the rest of their family died.
There was nobody carried for that person.
And now we have Christians running around with bass on
not talking to people, not living their life
because they're afraid of a virus
that you have a 99.97% chance of surviving.
Beyond me, I just tell you,
we're a state of Christianity in this country,
it's just sorrowful.
So, sorry, I'll get off my soapbox.
Any other questions, maybe don't pertain to that.
So I changed my mind here.
Remember, if you want to speak, you have to unmute yourself.
You have to unmute yourself.
I can't hear you.
I've got a lot of family and friends
that have taken the COVID vaccine
and I'm very concerned about that.
Is there anything that can do nutritionally or whatever?
Yeah, so we had, so I'm,
I'm going to mute you again while I answer that.
Okay, good, let's feed back there.
The, we had some,
we have a sister site.
So our website,
we've taken everything off of our website
that pertains to COVID.
Partially because,
you know, Joe Mercola, Dr. Mercola is,
he got strongly attacked by Google.
He actually had his site dig funded by Google
so he can't do Google ads or anything on his site.
If you search for Mercola,
it's difficult to find him.
You have to go right to his site address,
Dr. Mercola.com to find him.
Partly because he of his stance on COVID,
which was our stance on COVID,
but since he's not a cancer clinic,
he was putting a lot of information out about COVID
and they just basically took him down.
So we were like, okay, well, that's our purpose
is not to speak so much on vaccines in COVID
and we have to stay within our lane and our purpose.
So we don't want that to happen to us.
So let's be wise here.
We have a sister site that's called My Hope for Lime
and we had some more information on vaccines about that.
On that site, but we do have a document,
any of you guys want that document,
just email the clinic that you want the document on vaccines.
We have several documents on vaccines,
but what is how to help detoxify from vaccines?
And I can let's see, actually had it up here the other day.
The vaccine document looks like I can pull it up and show you
or I know, well, I won't,
because this will be on the live video.
So just email the clinic and ask for the vaccine detoxification
letter.
So we've compiled some as much information
that we found out there as possible.
The problem with this COVID vaccine
is that it's really not a vaccine.
It is a messenger RNA drug,
which creates an M spike protein in the cell,
which is going to create havoc if this person
is exposed to other coronaviruses in the future
like this fall.
So there may be a lot of problems with people health-wise
that were exposed to this vaccine that took the vaccine.
Can they detoxify that M spike protein?
Well, there isn't any research that shows that you can, unfortunately.
There are some wise things you can do to help with that
and to help reduce a hypo-histamine reaction
in the presence of a future exposure to other similar viruses
that will initiate a histamine-like response in the cell
from stimulating the M spike protein.
So in that article that we compiled,
that lists some of those things to do.
Also, if you are unvaccinated and you're exposed
to someone who have physical contact with somebody
that's vaccinated,
you could actually receive that M spike protein
not through shedding, but through exposure,
whereas a virus, if you're exposed to somebody who is a vaccine,
we're exposed to somebody who has a regular vaccine
that's called shedding,
but you can still get exposure to that M spike protein
and there's duverous reports of people that have had
blood clotting issues,
women that started bleeding vaginally again
that have already been through menopause five years ago
to women who have lost their babies
just because they're exposed to people at work that were vaccinated
even though they themselves weren't vaccinated.
The M spike protein can be transmitted to anybody,
any unvaccinated person from a vaccinated person
there can be danger.
There's belief that using different pine needles
evergreen needle T can be helpful with M spike protein.
There's other nutritional things that a person can do
with herbal things that a person can do
to help with the M spike protein that's in that document.
So just request that document.
We took that off of our website
just because we're a cancer clinic,
not a vaccine clinic and just we just thought
it'd be a disservice to our patients
to have our website go down because of that.
So just request that personally
and we'll give you that information personally
that can help those people and help you.
All right, any other questions?
Well, we had a good little Zoom call today.
I just thoroughly offended half you that are pro-vaccine.
So I apologize for that.
No, I don't, I don't apologize.
That's my opinion and you can throw it out the window
if you want but I feel very strongly about that
and I know other people feel very strongly
on the other side and that's okay
and we can agree to disagree.
All right, no more questions coming in.
We will bid a due and again, if you have questions
that you think of during the week,
please email those to us and oh, here's a nice comment.
Just a comment, thanks to you and your staff,
I've lived 1,350 days longer than the first doctor said I would.
I'll praise God for that and thank you for being thankful
and I know you are thankful to the Lord first
and but we thank each other
because we're a team and a family and we love each other
and we're praying for each other.
So thanks everybody who's prayed for everybody else
and I would really encourage you to become a prayer warrior
if you feel like you lost your way
or you lost your purpose in life.
Make that to be a prayer warrior for others
and that will be well served.
Okay, somebody popped it in a video chat.
If you do have a question,
you're gonna have to unmute yourself.
Nope, all right, well thank you everybody.
We will say goodbye and talk to everybody next week.